we got this op-ed from The Washington
Post for the good of the country Biden
and Harris should bow out of the 2024
election from George will this story
went viral uh today this guy voted for
Joe Biden he hates Trump votes for Joe
Biden and now he's like what did he say
that Joe Biden has displayed
unwittingness or what is it what does he
call it I don't care to read the whole
thing the fact is everyone's basically
saying oh here we go this is great he
says meeting recently with some
Progressive activists Biden said his 426
billion dollar student loan forgiveness
was accomplished by a law that he had
just signed I got it passed by a vote or
two no he did not I love this because
it's two things the first thing is it's
a guy who voted for Biden being like no
no more Biden the second thing is well I
mean actually it's it's calling for
Biden to bow out and it's a guy
regretting having voted for him in the
first place so I you love to see it this
is what you get when you vote for a man
who is insane unwell is out of it and
now he's going on TV and just lying and
making things up and that's that's it's
absolutely Fascinating People still buy
it it's absolutely fascinating that
people will still vote for someone like
John fetterman Joe Biden claimed his son
died in Iraq twice now he claimed he got
a bill passed he didn't get past and
people believe it they call Trump a
fascist but you want to talk about
fascism that's the fascism right there
that's the scary thing they sneak it in
with some bumbling old daughter who
makes random things up people buy it
they they March in lockstep behind it
but I'm glad to see that these never
trumpers are regretting their actions
and now calling for a substantial change
I guess the question is if not Biden
2024 not Harris who could it possibly be
I think it's honestly going to be
someone who is just like Biden at the
end of the day they go make new promises
say they're gonna be something different
it's gonna be the same thing repeating
Stacy Abrams no no Michelle Obama and
Oprah both of them running on the same
ticket why wouldn't it happen tell me
make an argument I think that's who else
is there Gavin Newsom yeah but the
serial killer looking dude and then that
crazy woman which more uh which more I
said that by accident now I just kind of
realized we gotta write that down
seriously the The Butcher of the nursing
home uh people seriously who else is
there Pete budigen he's I mean
those are the only other two has
connections to intelligence so he's
going to be propped up in there he's in
the administration now he's uh Megan
McCain no she doesn't have enough star
power at the moment who else well you
got nobody Hillary you're gonna bring
you're gonna dust Hillary off I don't
think she wants bring her foreign
I've been thinking about Hillary a lot
lately I think she's not alive
because she's one of those you know they
say facts over feelings a lot of people
feelings Hillary's like the ultimate
feelings over facts person I feel like I
just realized this that if she likes you
she wants to work with you if she gets a
gut feeling like yeah yeah like she
could be she could be swayed to do you
see what you just said huh that people
are going to vote Republican because
they're too stupid to know what's good
for him she senses the emotions now I'm
paraphrasing what she really said is
that low information Americans don't
realize what a red wave actually means
for them but you know she's basically
saying y'all are too stupid to know
what's good for you so Lindbergh said
the same thing not Hillary not Bloomberg
I don't know who do you guys do you guys
see even hey she's too young she'll be
old enough but Michelle Obama Oprah I'm
telling you Obama Oprah
Kanye you're telling me they would lose
I don't think they would lose no no I
don't know I would have said that maybe
four years ago but times they are a
change in men and I'll tell you why
you take a look at some of the cultural
Productions and they have no impact The
Daily Show getting only a few hundred
thousand views like people believe in
different things maybe maybe seven eight
years ago you'd be like Oprah's so
popular people would vote for today
people are less concerned about pop
culture politics has become pop culture
so they're not going to vote for someone
like Oprah I mean she'd get votes don't
get me wrong she'd get a lot Michelle
Obama yes former first lady absolutely
maybe it's going to be Obama Clinton or
Clinton Obama
which Clinton
Chelsea Chelsea no no politics Chelsea
it's going to be it'll be like a tech a
tech billionaire
could do it oh musk no he's not American
he's he's not he can never run for
president
uh Jeff Jeff's not gonna do it I don't
know I mean all of a sudden the
Washington Post that's writing we need a
billionaire president to fix things
Amazon is the greatest company ever Jeff
Bezos soars in the polls and then you
you know you understand why he bought it
the rock comically evil yeah yeah I mean
he's playing a little bit into politics
he supported Gavin Newsom he did a whole
political advertisement for him so and
he's he'll say anything for a buck I
mean look at the kind of movie he's in I
think he's not as bad as that that other
dude who did that Chinese ad yeah what's
his name John Cena John Cena when I say
that's Pete butterjudge and you guys
like no no stop is it because you really
are afraid that he might win no come on
because it's like saying Mickey Mouse
you don't think has a chance no oh I
thought he doesn't have a personality he
doesn't have anything he like remember
when he disappeared for like a month or
something and no one knew it was gone
and it was like a major crisis is with
Trucking and Fuel and they're all like
don't we have a guy for this and he was
just gone like nobody knew nobody cared
so I definitely don't see that guy but
also would you want to be a politician
in a falling Empire everyone's gonna
blame you for for all the horrible
things that all the other politicians
have kind of built up what if what if
this isn't the fall of the Roman Empire
this is the fall of the Roman Republic
what if Trump crosses the Rubicon and we
become a country that the Republicans
just keep winning because the Democrats
are psychotic and you end up with a
lopsided country that's like 55 percent
Republican or at the very least
Independence voting Republican because
we've been traumatized by psychotic
Democrats sterilizing kids and and
things like that shutting down gas and
then you end up with a long period of
just consistent Republican majorities
maybe but the difference is that it's
like a global
um immersion now whereas the Romans were
still pretty insulated when the Republic
fell now we've got like every country on
earth is attempting to create a new
government in the United States and it's
kind of up to us to hold the wheel while
the storm rages outside who do you think
Miles who would have your vote I'm
actually hope I'm hoping no one who's in
the Democratic party collapse and then
via Republican uh system we could just
take over the entire thing in Happy Days
for a while I mean look the Republicans
are bad for a lot of reasons but we're
seeing the split where you have
establishment Republicans and you have
Maga Republicans if the Republicans win
in a sweeping Victory then they win in
2024 and the Democrats become diminished
you may actually see the dominant party
become Republicans and this is a very
very wild hypothetical
if the Democrats can't get a consistent
majority of Republicans eventually
they'll start jumping ship to try and
influence the Republican party which
will then split and take over the
two-party system I'm not convinced
something like that could like will
happen but it's a possibility if one
political party
I'll put it this way the modern
Republicans are very different from the
establishment but people are willing to
vote for any Republican at this point
because the Democrats are insane they're
campaigning on abortion as CR while
crime is skyrocketing in major cities in
New York there was like 30 people have
been pushed in front of trains like
that's freaking people out so
Republicans are like okay we'll stop
crime and now you get widely different
views you get post liberals people like
me voting Republican even though I
disagree with a lot of policies the
Democrats are just too nuts if that
keeps up for a little while eventually
then you're going to see the Maga
Republicans and the neocon types and
establishment types split and that will
become the actual two parties right
there
crazy run or Civil War
well I don't know about that I mean
Civil War if the far left loses it and
refuses to accept the result of the
election look Joe Biden spoke today
about the the danger of election denials
or whatever deny deniers and I think
it's funny because the message is is
deeply needed right now because when the
Republicans win next week and it's
tremendous and insane they're going to
need to come out and be like remember
what Biden said don't deny the elections
but you know they're going to do it gosh
I think that people should be allowed uh
and all maybe not encouraged to deny
elections but you should certainly be
allowed to posit that there are issues
in your elections especially with
evidence coming out of computer programs
hacking and flipping vote tallies but
but you can only do that if you come
from a certain political party if you're
from a different political party you're
going to be censored you're going to be
banned you're going to be punished
you're going to be ostracized by
Mainline society and called Dangerous by
Homeland Security but if you're Stacy
Abrams you could do it all the time did
you see it doesn't matter in Brazil
there's like giant crowds tens of
thousands of people demanding the
military come out and say this election
there's a huge protest today too it's
crazy they went to like the military HQ
that's scary man it's scary when you're
when when you're when your country
tribalizes that degree it it you know
what man I think
you look at someone like Trump or
bolsonaro I think they know what happens
if you really move forward with a move
like that
it's not going to be fun people are not
going to live good lives like you you
will have massive suffering it could
start a Civil War and anybody who's
actually seen conflicts knows exactly
why you do not want something like that
yeah I was thinking about the crowds in
Brazil saying that we think that
bolsonaro was illegally uh voted out we
think the election was fraudulent and we
want the military to do what if they're
wrong like what have they done what they
have tens hundreds
of getting the military involved like
right what they don't care they don't
care for a lot of people it's about the
truth but they're being it's being used
right now I will say you've got a lot of
people in the United States
agreeing with the protesters
I've not seen anything out of Brazil so
I I'm not going to say I know for sure
what's going on but I'll tell you
it's it's feelings over fact the facts
don't matter the feelings do and these
people are thinking one thing if
bolsonaro is not the president Brazil
suffers so it doesn't matter what
happened it matters that they do
whatever they can to make sure he stays
president yeah they block the highways
and asked the military to take over the
government that's that's serious come on
did you ever see any kind of civil
conflict I mean the the closest thing I
that I saw when it comes to something
like a Civil War was was what I saw in
Mogadishu Somalia different tribes and
different factions of people fighting
each other uh you know roadside bombs
and just shelling and fighting all you
know but but have you seen anything like
that oh yeah even in Brazil I've seen
leaked videos
um showing that the cartel was
celebrating that the guy got elected
because he's gonna protect him and you
think with how corrupt certain parts of
Brazil you know something was uh messed
with I honestly think at the end of the
day but I've seen stuff in South Sudan
as well so it doesn't matter who you
belong to in the country it just belongs
about the tribe so it doesn't matter to
be South sunnis South Sudan doesn't
really exist it's just about the tribal
people and the borders don't make it
yeah what happened yes so well real
quick like Brazil is let's just say
there's a lot of things about Brazil I
was down there and I saw the
pacification or the REM the aftermath of
the pacification the government went in
these were brutal videos they just
basically took over favelas the
government was so broken that for a long
time gangs in favelas were de facto
governments now they're trying to gain
control over all these territories I
don't think you're going to see
confidence in any of these systems but I
want to stress we're not Brazilian I
don't know what's going on in Brazil
other than we're watching news reports
about it and people are demanding the
military takeover so yeah I want
evidence if any I'm not going to make
claims without evidence that's for sure
but it's not it's not even that I mean
we're not Brazilian I don't even know
what like if someone came to you right
now and said like Miguel you know Perez
came out and showed this document like
dude I have no idea what you're talking
about I don't even know who that is the
issue is so if if something really bad
happens in Brazil there'll be another
immigration issue where they will go at
the Darian Gap all the way and cross the
border like what happened with Venezuela
too when the country fell though
Brazil's massive yeah I think I think
they can make it happen
um they got dollar coconuts in Rio I
don't want to be too bad yeah but at the
same time these people see American
thing oh better life there's no election
corruption over here I'm gonna I'm gonna
I'm gonna tell you this I I take anybody
who goes to the military and request
they take over I'm not trusting to be
completely honest like that's the last
thing anyone would want if you if you
think you legitimately won you then go
to the military and ask them to take
over your country it doesn't sound yeah
that's what some of the protesters are
no for sure and uh yeah I I don't think
bolsonaro is doing it I think he
officially conceded today he didn't
concede okay did he I think so I think I
saw something right before this
broadcast with him announcing that he's
officially letting uh I know I know that
he was basically he was beginning the
transition but I heard that he didn't
concede what do you see uh I read a post
on Reddit sing specifically that he did
concede yeah but again it's Reddit could
be wrong we don't know what's going on
yesterday he had not conceded yeah you
might be right but the transition was
beginning like he was letting go with
power and following the Constitution
that's that's what it was reported
I certainly hope you don't see a
military takeover man that's not fun
stuff no no but uh anyway Sudan
yeah South Sudan's uh world's newest
country it definitely shows at the end
of the day uh bribery is right if you go
around anywhere you have to pay money
especially if you're a foreigner like
myself you stand out like a sore thumb
for you and bears keeping the entire
country on uh Lifeline so they're just
handing out free foods and everything
but not actually uh funding any
Agriculture and bringing some uh farming
techniques to teach them how to be
self-sufficient it's just a money scene
for money laundering the rich uh people
get richer because the uh the money
given by the UN our governments as well
is going to Bear pocket instead of the
average person living in a mud hut who
doesn't have enough food to eat today it
sucks and I think that could happen in
Brazil the end of the day you can get
more tribal people fight
um amongst themselves like you said to
him you've got uh you've got people that
are belonging to certain areas uh not
actually the governments and Country as
a whole and they'll associate with their
tribal groups and then just fight
amongst themselves and I I think Brazil
could for winter that he could even get
to a point where Stone Parts in Brazil
separate because the geography of a
country is so insane that I would make
sense at the end of the day and Boston
Arrow just I'm just I'm just looking at
it right now he is urging his supporters
to stop the roadblocks and he has
authorized the transition didn't concede
yet so the Reddit post Rose wrong thanks
for checking out this segment from the
timcast IRL podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
Monday through Friday at 8 pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the timcast IRL podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
Monday through Friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there